tiens alors on va en savoir un petit peu
plus sur vous en landau ont fait faire
une hardy view
alors dos vous pensez à quoi en ce
moment là je suis légèrement déstabilisé
pourquoi le début peut-être parce que
dans la loge de maquillage est arrivé
derrière moi pleurons il l'a poussé
christine on aurait dit un corbeau
c'était comment le trader qui tellement
content de le voir arriver les quotas
aux citoyens
sélima pelé savicevic aînés viennent que
s'il ya baffie régira ci a pas vraiment
cette action aux libanais orlando à qui
vous auriez aimé ressembler quand vous
étiez petit orlando brad pitt s'arrêtait
pas mal mais ton coup j'aurais préféré
voilà quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois
ces avis cela semble être la dernière je
pense que je suis de plus en plus émotif
voilà donc il une chanson une voix
quelque l'artiste aujourd'hui vous allez
tous connus quel artiste peut vous que
vous tirer des larmes hollande
aujourd'hui record
millions d'origine celle incluant est
alors vous changeriez quoi on joue là
comme ça aujourd'hui si vous aviez une
baguette magique d'avoir tout de suite
comme sa première avoir 20 centimètres
de plus ou quel est le péché qui vous
touche le plus kim et tente le plus
séduit des pouvoirs un obtenir la
personne que nous ne voudrais pas c'est
à dire 'voilà ce sera d'obtenir un viol
et de trois péchés qui rôdent en ce
moment là haut de temps en temps ou et
vous savez plus fous de plusieurs fois
dans la journée de régates et de
s'évader légal comme on dit qu'est ce
que vous pourriez dire orlando de plus
négatif sur vous quand il faut courir
vraiment la colère et je suis quelqu'un
de tel qu'un orlando galles et
l'insultent qui vous a fait le plus mal
j'ai en fait je pense que je suis
quelqu'un de feu mais c'est difficile et
ses prétentions de profondément honnête
voilà des comptes qu'on doute de ma
parole ou conduire quelqu'un vous a
traité d' escroc un jour il s'agit des
malhonnêtes c'est la chose qui pourrait
vraiment mes maîtres blaise intervient
alors que le téléphone sonne est ce que
vous êtes heureux ou agacé est ce que tu
vas personnaliser la sonnerie de
portable
est ce que c'est une chanson de ta soeur
quand ça sonne ça fait quoi quand et
comme souvent taxé il venait d'avoir 18
ans orlando
vous feriez quoi si vous restez 24
heures à vivre près de changer la vitre
je sais pas j'ai serré de de mettre tout
en ordre avant que je parte je suis
quelqu'un de magna je suis maniaque de
leur profonde radiant douala et je pense
que je les ferai tout pour que les gens
après que je parte chacune finance à la
savoie là il y avait sa sphère sait s'il
y avait ça reste à fait noir est tout à
fait adéquat la cites rester 24 heures à
vivre
j'irai tout ranger chez orlando
quand je bosse en question avait déjà
répondu ouais pendant une maison à
crédit ça me rassure un petit crédit sur
15 ans ça me ferait du bien dans leur
dos et dieu dans tout ça
dieu dieu il est là dit je sais rien il
faut qu'on soit honnête parce qu'on
s'arrange
il existe surtout quand on a besoin de
lui voilà dieu est au mathis par tous
les soirs
à lisieux